it's time Bon Appetit  [Music]  as far back as I can recall we have been  at war every so often something occurs  to tip the scales this is where it gets  complicated sorry Ari  nothing personal  Austin was West welcome to  I want to hurry someone wants to kill my  husband to me he is the president after  all I wanna who's the top of this  pyramid the hidden but someone out there  knows I want to know everything  did you know what dairy was good lord  are you one of them too I'm dealing with  some very unpleasant people the stakes  are a lot higher now I can handle it  still don't debate me to death threats  backed up by murder  somebody's tying up loose ends  don't them dumb I have to do this  [Music]  [Music]